alambre de púas y barricadas protegen la
comisión europea un mensaje claro para
los manifestantes no son bienvenidos las
autoridades belgas prohibieron el
bloqueo de bruselas y advirtieron en
contra de cualquier intento de
introducir en la ciudad un convoy de la
libertad al estilo de canadá la policía
estaba canalizando los vehículos hacia
las afueras donde sólo se permitía un
plantón contra las restricciones
impuestas por la pandemia
pedimos libertad que se detenga la
vacuna o el pase sanitario y que no
obliguen a la gente a vacunarse muchos
manifestantes habían viajado desde
francia que a su vez estuvieron en parís
durante el fin de semana la policía
impidió en gran medida que los
conductores accedieron a la ciudad un
centenar de vehículos entró a la avenida
de los campos elíseos o enfrentamientos
y decenas fueron detenidos a pesar de
que el gobierno apunta a planes para
relajar los mandatos de las mascarillas
a finales de mes e incluso la esperanza
de detener el proyecto de su pase de
vacunas para marzo o abril
los manifestantes se inspiran en una
caravana similar en canadá una que
paralizó la capital del país durante
tres semanas y que bloqueó tres pasos
fronterizos clave que unen con eeuu por
el puente ambassador en ontario cruza
una cuarta parte de todo el comercio
entre ambos países su reapertura se
logró el fin de semana para el alivio de
las autoridades la policía ha tratado de
manejar esto de una manera mesurada no
ha habido violencia y lo agradecemos
mucho ese era el objetivo desde el
principio aún así la ira generada por
las restricciones por el coronavirus se
mantiene otros países como nueva zelanda
australia países bajos e israel han
visto como movimientos similares cada
vez toman más fuerza
[Aplausos]